notice that millennials
don't seem to care about the character
of the person they don't care about
what's inside they just seem to be
shallow and care about what's on the
outside how much money you have we live
who your friends are is that true yes
and why is that how did it become that
way it wasn't always that way well it
was because before it was birth control
that's what I think started everything
was because that's what if you look at
the divorce rate and the rate of women
on birth control they're like the same
and so what I think it was is basically
the hose
what do birth control give you house
right and so before like women had to
prioritize a guy that had good character
and would stick around right but then
when you give them birth control it
gives them the opportunity to sleep with
like for for shallow things right and
the problem is that
um women are bailed out for every bad
decision we made yeah so it's like if we
if we sleep around there's birth control
if we if birth control fails there's
abortion child support and divorce court
and out even alimony I'm like you get
money for just being married to him no
shut up get a job and and then um on top
of that if we're bad with our money like
there's there's a lot of government
bailout programs like in the UK they
give you free housing if you're a single
mother if you pay women yeah if if you
pay women to I think men and women can
be equally shitty and they but women are
paid to be bad so of course we're going
to be worse yeah yeah that's amazing
they're starting to do that here too
give them free houses free health care
everything yeah and it's like
I know and I I have no children
call bad bad call evil yeah um so you do
you just deal with women issues
um or do you talk to men as well no I
have both on my show so I'll just bring
in so I do a live show four times a week
in a studio kind of
it's just in my living room right but
that's amazing yeah but what I do is um
we bring in between like five to ten
guys and girls and we'll talk about like
different topics sometimes it's things
like the pay Gap other times it's things
like
you know can modern women be saved can
you turn a hoe into a housewife like
that sort of
um
um so can you turn a [__] into a
housewife well of course not you cannot
well okay this is my my theory it
happens sometimes yeah but they always
go back to the streets yeah the streets
we call them so like they might they
might get it for a little bit but
they'll just divorce them
yeah I tell men that that want to start
a family that they should not marry an
educated woman who doesn't want to stay
home and be a a wife and a mother
because she would not mate for a good
mother am I raw no you're right I'm
right yeah
um why do you think man go ahead no go
ahead why would you not want to spend
time with your children right that's
kind of a bad bomb if you don't want to
spend time with yourself I know isn't
that amazing yeah yeah they prefer to go
out and pretend to be a man in the race
just stay home with the kids yeah yeah
what a mess why would why do men marry
women like that
well they don't have options like
because we have one in three men are
under 30 are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year so it's like
there's a growing there's a growing
number of simps there's a simple
epidemic yeah and it's because like they
don't think they can do better that's my
my opinion on it anyway but the option
is they don't have to get married yeah
it's not like you gotta Gotta Get
Married yeah but
there's kind of there's a saying in red
pill which is like they always get
married even the guys that say that
they'll never get married they always
get married and it's kind of like I
don't know I think I think men are more
romantic than women like I think they
just want a family and a wife right they
do and so it's like if if they can't get
the girls they want they kind of just
take what they can get where women will
die alone but yeah I know mental more
like ah yeah they want a family yeah
I'll take the used Honda Civic with a
lot of miles a lot of a lot of miles
that's right what is a uh so red pill
and then the other one is blue pill yeah
or black people well there's a couple
um blue pill is
like guys that aren't aware of these
things so like for example someone
that's blue pill might marry a single
mother but like that's that's kind of
like something someone blue Pillow could
do because they're told like that's the
right thing to do or a mess yeah I'm
nice yeah someone where someone red pill
would say ah no your recreational use
only right and black pill is usually
guys that are black pill believe
everything starts with looks so they
they're very much like if you're short
it may not be over but it's close to
over for you if you're five two five
three it's like ah wow good luck
who come up with all these ideas how do
these things come about red pure blue
pure
it's a good question I don't I don't I
don't know who started black pill
there's mgtow too which is men going
their own way
yeah they're like yeah [__] these hoes
leave them in the streets
um I I don't think he would say that he
started it I think there was one or two
before him okay they say Patrice O'Neal
while he wasn't like a typical like red
pillar but a lot of the ideas like kind
of were in his jokes oh okay yeah so
um women this uh this group going go
your own way right women are men men
yeah men going their own way yes their
own way women need men to guide them
right and so is that a good idea to just
because you failed at it a couple of
times should you get it right or walk
away from women
amen yeah
um
I understand why men are walking away
from Marriage yeah um I I don't
necessarily I wouldn't say that you
should walk away from women altogether
like at least I mean recreational what
are you gonna okay I just feel like you
know you said recreational you mean like
for sex yeah
I'm just like there's a lot of I don't
know
men are walking away from marriage
because they get a bad deal
and that's that's like one thing I
didn't when I first started watching red
pill content I was like I grew up in a
two-parent household and my parents are
still married so I never understood like
why men walk away from Marriage until I
realized it's like a contract that women
are paid to leave yeah and you can take
half of his earnings which doesn't even
make sense like why are you entitled to
half of the money that he made and you
don't even have kids and so and on top
of that like the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31 here it's like
28 for women and so men value Purity and
youth and they don't get either of those
things yeah from women today so it's
like what a mess yeah yeah I understand
why you know it's like City girl culture
um
yeah you're right that's what it is yeah
absolutely right
um
men they don't seem to be as strong
today as they were in the good old days
what happened to them they listened to
women stop it we don't know what we want
yeah
exactly I tell them all the time every
time you listen to the woman you suffer
and and I also I've heard testosterone
levels are like lower than ever before
so I don't know if it's something with
like the food or lifestyle or what
exactly it is but yeah I would say
that's part of it too but that's amazing
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible